[Music]
all right well
uh you guys know nintendo right love
nintendo
i think i know where this is going oh
you know i think so oh
tell me so my dad works microsoft
long time ago released this story where
they were about to buy nintendo
and then they were laughed out of the
[ __ ] room
and they laughed hours at microsoft what
nintendo was laughing at microsoft yeah
so microsoft back in the day i think it
was
in the 90s or whatever right they wanted
to collaborate with nintendo yeah
and then nintendo they just wanted to
like kind of
visit the idea of maybe we can buy
nintendo and then they're like
laughing in their face for like three
hours straight did you know that
nintendo and sony actually collaborated
for a very very brief time before the
n64 or playstation
playstation came out and they made a
console that was in test mode only
really it was like very very early i i
don't even know but they never released
it they never released it it's crazy and
they had a falling out but like yeah
playstation and nintendo were working
together at one point yeah but then
microsoft approached before they did the
whole xbox and things like that and
nintendo again and they're like yo check
it out you guys are great at making
games why don't we do the hardware for
you
and then kind of like at this time there
was already playstation and sony that
collaborated right so so they're like we
can be like that and then
yeah but they still didn't take deal
is it the same is this the story no oh
nintendo was smart though because they
still
were like number one even true nintendo
we came out they made a comeback with
the wii
yeah and the switch was what they were
doing yeah this was just sold out
forever
they owned a brothel at one point too in
the early days yeah
they did really well with that too i
heard well there were conglomerates
with sony on that brothel i heard that
no this story is different so this one
is uh
an artist is claiming that
an official super nintendo world website
is using
his fan art and so it's kind of ironic
because nintendo is known for being one
of the most protective
yes and litigious ip holders in the
video game industry
if you do a like a game stream they
could come after you potentially
really wow wouldn't that help them like
crazed right now well they they didn't
never
accepted that into their model like they
have a very old world way of looking at
all this it's like japanese dinosaurs
that are running it like if you go in
there
it smells like fossils and they've been
successful so they have every reason to
think that they're right i don't know
what fossils smell like
like you should smell them raw and sushi
i'm just kidding i don't know but
they're ceos in the executives it's
pretty funny
it's pretty crazy to try to own fan art
though
that's hard yeah well maybe i don't know
what happened here so um so this fan he
tweeted out
i love how nintendo used my old ass
mario render
in their official nintendo world website
it'd be great if it was mario [ __ ]
peach by the way
stupid so this is what you see when you
enter the website
wait uh this is his art that's the fan
art the other thing
it looks official like anything else
what is this
what did you make dude yeah he does like
3d rendering at least put mario's [ __ ]
through peach while she's like
cut her legs out or something she's
that's at least a little different than
what we see in the games
that i mean i wouldn't be able to tell
that's not
authentic and it's fan art like it's so
[ __ ] good it's so generic yeah
neither would i so what if the company
thought that they were like oh mario and
then they look for that and
i'm gonna put this on the website well
that's what happened
they thought it was theirs what is
theirs we are mario
yeah so i honestly can't tell a
different but apparently there's like
slight differences where this one has
like a little bit more shadows
i can't tell i can't even tell if you
were a fan
wouldn't you be honored because here's
the thing actually what he's saying he's
like i'm actually
really honored that my work even got any
recognition at all
um and that's why i'm suing he's not
telling me
so like as a okay as an artist
you can like let's say take uh
uh mickey or whatever right and then you
can do your own art if you're not
selling it you're not violating
copyright if they were selling it
he would have uh violated copyright so
so like is it even his
it's his work but can he license can he
fight nintendo for it like how does that
even work you can't sell prince
yeah that's confusing yeah but if
there's maria's [ __ ] going through
peaceful she's got a leg
that's his creations [ __ ] that's his own
[ __ ] i think
that's very that sometimes happens when
i when i'm browsing through my
uh my hobby of porn yeah sometimes i'm
like oh simpsons and it's like wait
marge is sucking dick
like whoa marge is getting [ __ ] in a
way that i didn't think was possible but
she is a cartoon though right
so i have to be open-minded about that
yeah yeah okay
yeah so uh i don't know so
this artist this is a quote that he said
um this is what it was good in japanese
accent japanese accent please
no i'm so used to my mario renders
getting very little attention i'm being
told to take action on the matter but i
find it very nice to finally have some
recognition on it
and so uh he says for my render to be
mistaken for an official one shows i'm
kind of doing something right here
so he was just like oh that's pretty
cool but the thing is like the reason
why i got so much attention is because
once again it's so
ironic because they are like so on
everyone's asses
about about using their [ __ ] but then
all of a sudden
yeah that makes sense artwork um but
he ended up tweeting out looks like they
finally
fixed the image i was never contacted
back but i believe this is a result of
my email
and this is the new image which looks
identical to me i don't even know
look i'll show you guys
[Applause]
it they're slightly what so there's
slight changes okay
the thing i noticed in the bill of the
hat there's actually a color variation
that's oh that's literally it the thing
i noticed was like the overalls
the overalls look slightly different let
me open the other one okay
but yeah i remember the color variation
remember that
why did they just get their
own so this is the one that just doesn't
make any sense this is the one i just
showed you
this is his build a hat little less shot
there's no shine see
boom what i see the overall buttons i
guess
this is oh wait and this is the other
this is the one that he's saying
i don't understand why nintendo dish
didn't get their own [ __ ]
and then put it up like it's like oh is
that someone else all right let's get
another one instead of
taking that [ __ ] and then [ __ ]
changing it three different ways and
then posting it
yeah no so i i think that's what they
did i think they just
got one of their own i'm not sure oh he
just never contacted him
even though he emailed and he just got
ignored pretty much but it's just like
damn nintendo you come in and [ __ ]
attack other people
what if what if it's not nintendo what
if it's like he
someone that was lazy building the
website [ __ ]
you know what it was you know anthony or
something right he was just doing it and
he's like
holy [ __ ] i mean big [ __ ] right and he
[ __ ] changed it he was okay
pulling concept images and all that kind
of stuff yeah what's the history with
with nintendo and the italian
plumber like why why did they do you
guys know like why
that was like their character yeah
they're i [ __ ] read it because i was
like
wondering yeah i read it too so donkey
kong so donkey kong actually was the bad
guy to mario's good guy and mario
was designed to have overalls and like
like the hat and
whatever like the shape of mario yeah he
was a jump man
yeah jump man it was easier to design a
character though to look like that
through the middle minimal pixels that
the original
nintendo game gaming platform had yeah
and so it looks like they don't have the
backstory yet
yeah so then because of the overall look
and they knew his name was jumpman
they they then later on filled in the
blanks with he's a plumber
so they're designing based off of the
technology that was available then
first and they made the character a
little called him jumpman initially it
wasn't i think it was a rebrand in
america though
like it was man i forgot what it was i
read it too i was like yeah this is so
interesting and i [ __ ] forgot all
about it
but it was like someone um
it was it was super simple like it was
like someone in the company that was
like
oh yeah mario yeah
genius it was like it was like it was
like that i was like oh it was just
some simple [ __ ] and it was like
digestible for americans that's what
they thought
yeah they were wrong we never adopted it
[Laughter]
that's my favorite
i play this thing called be real cart
i've played it
it's fun it's dangerous cheerio like you
like mario burial you have to chug an
entire beer right
yeah so you start the game yep you're
playing mario kart
and they say the three laps you're your
cart you have a
like say a um uh open can a bottle you
pour into a glass
or a cup it's in the kitchen or
somewhere else uh this is the way we
play
and as you're playing if you want you
have to finish the drink before you
finish the race yes
oh there's three laps and there's
strategy you could start right away
people run there you could get them
going you go to like the last lap
whatever you want to do
but you have to finish the the whole
drink and you have to put your
controller back down on the table
so you can't you can't drink and drive
you cannot drink and drive and it's a
different really drinking responsibility
and you have to stop to drink yeah but
then you can drive after you drink
though
that's not very i think it's a very good
rule yes so it's actually a lot of fun
it sounds kind of fun you play like
three rounds and it's like you're [ __ ]
up dude come over i got the mario kart
and i got the beard don't worry about it
do you have all the games where it's
like the hundreds of games
no you have that uh cap does and we play
all the [ __ ] time and it's
so much [ __ ] does he have like an
arcade like with with everything in it
one console like yeah what is that is it
raspberry pi what is that
oh it's um you can uh program raspberry
pi is like a pretty
like um user-friendly thing that you can
um program and download every [ __ ]
game that ever existed from
a tiny and affordable computer you can
use to learn programming through
no it's a nintendo switch a lot of
people use emulators through raspberry
pi and they plug them into tvs and they
just
have like every [ __ ] game ever it's
just a nintendo switch
and it's and it's i guess like the mario
party game and it has like hundreds of
little mini games
but there's so much [ __ ] fun there's
like you're talking about marion party
yeah
that there's like hundreds of mini games
i know mario so much [ __ ] fun the way
you put it was different but yeah i said
hundreds of little games
all right my bad dude you could get the
nintendo console that has
800 nintendo games in it it's like one
box it's already in it
it just yeah it just looks like the old
[Music]
console
foreign